and get started want to welcome everyone
to the device Thursday noon conference
and today is also what we call an IDL
talk IDL standing for the informatics
discovery lab which is a new initiative
in the department that many of you know
about that is looking at trying to build
bridges external to the University
especially to industry but with other
partners as well and so today we have a
speaker from epic who many of you know
of epic and we've had an enjoyable week
working with them looking at ways that
we can and make our academic program
function work better with them give
students and actually faculty access and
and so forth so our speaker today is dr.
Brett shillings dead who is a physician
who works for epic he's part of their
clinical informatics team by background
he's a board certified general surgeon
and previously was co-owner and
co-manager of a multi-specialty group
practice and while in practice used
several different electronic health
record systems voice recognition
software and then in 2004 a transition
to working for epic and he's involved in
many aspects of the epic system there
and I had the opportunity to get to meet
him earlier this year and we started
talking and it's it's evolved to this
and we really hope that this will be the
beginning of mutually beneficial
collaboration between the informatics
program and epic and not not only on the
clinical side I see a bunch of
bioinformatics folks here to epics
plowing ahead in that area as well data
analytics all of the areas that
are really driving informatics Brett
actually comes actually as a native of
the Northwest sort of grew up in Montana
attended Carroll College there and then
went to medical school at University of
New Mexico and Albuquerque he did his
residency in surgery at the case western
reserve in Cleveland and then also there
did a fellowship in surgical endoscopy
so he's going to talk to us today about
relationships between informatics and
clinical end users into to come here
today is the mic working or hopefully it
is okay and I wanted to cover a number
of different areas and give you some
ideas and will certainly leave enough
time at the end for questions and
answers and certainly anything you want
to ask I'm happy to try to answer
there's been a lot of factors affecting
electronic health records as we all know
with the Affordable Care Act and
meaningful use there's been tremendous
amounts of money out there we've seen a
huge movement from paper to electronic
one of the things that's amazed me most
traveling the world is how the United
States really currently is about two to
three generations ahead of Europe and
the rest of the world which is something
that may be somewhat of a surprise and
actually Singapore Middle East and most
of Europe is adopting us systems because
we're actually currently the leader and
that's led to a lot of changing roles
with vendors forging ahead ah what are
the partnerships with academics how do
we integrate stuff such as genomics and
personalized medicine and how does
meaningful use compliance and
professional organizations fit into this
I think there are some things that are
definitely hampering and slowing
development items such as meaningful use
which help get medical use medical
records more used is also slowing it
down because it can take weeks to figure
out how to implement meaningful use
requirements
um certainly who's going to control
medical IT is it going to be more
vendors government or academics what are
the areas we can work together and
certainly trying to figure out where
those partnerships are is important okay
so I think some of the areas that I'd
like to touch on where there's some
natural areas for partnerships is
providing a maintaining evidence-based
content many of the medium to smaller
customers throughout the country have no
bandwidth to maintain their content
hospitals of 50 to 250 beds have no way
to keep order sets templates and
everything up to date how can academic
centers host that content and make that
available real-time clinical or
cognitive decision support epic supports
the capability of using web services to
host that and actually allowing
customers to subscribe to true clinical
decision support certainly interpreting
and integrating basic science
breakthroughs into the electronic health
record areas such as genomics certainly
the area we'd all like to get to is
instead of just having generic protocols
actually looking at patient attributes
and coming up with areas where we can
deploy personalized medicine the other
areas leading meaningful use in
compliance rather than a government when
the government comes up with these
criteria very difficult to employ these
because they never consider what data is
captured during a workflow they never
consider how it's going to be reported
and many times what they choose is not
necessarily things that are going to
improve outcomes for example having pre
coordinated data elements like EKG in
the past year kind of meaningful
meaningless you know it's better to
capture EKG and then have a post
coordinated attribute of the date and by
having people who understand informatics
help with this stuff is going to make it
much more easy to comply with
and then certainly developing the health
record and clinic of the future your
simulation center is very exciting i'm
going to show some of the ideas we have
at epic and we'd love over time to get
the ideas that you have as you start
doing simulations as to how we can
better interface end users patients in
the hardware that they use so
evidence-based content as we talked
about many of the early adopters where
academic centers they're the ones they
actually create the evidence based
content most of the late adopters are
smaller to medium sized hospitals who
don't have the bandwidth to do that and
there's really a clamor as to how they
are going to with a very small team and
being non-academic stay up to date with
with the content that they need and some
of the ways that we can do that is by
pushing that content out to them and it
can be hosted externally so I'm just
going to show you a few examples of what
that might look like here this is
actually a patient who has a stroke and
we have some stroke guidelines and one
of the ways that this currently works
with up-to-date health wise and other
content vendors is you can actually with
a single click using an alert or by
right clicking on a diagnosis you can
pull in the current guidelines and this
is where we're currently at kind of an
info button type approach but one of the
infrastructure areas that exists is the
area the ability to put in XML objects
within these documents so you can see
the blue fields here and for areas where
customer did not have order sets or
wasn't maintaining them you can actually
make these actionable so you can see for
a stroke I should get a CBC check a
cholesterol level maybe get a duplex
Doppler ultrasound and this is actually
generating orders based on the XML tags
within the document this is something
that would go a step beyond actually
providing just content within a document
the next level would be actually sending
attributes of the patient out to ascend
server that ran algorithms and then
based on that patients personal
characteristics sent back a document
that was even more specific with
actionable items within the document
many people have looked at doing this
this is current functionality but really
having academic centers such as
yourselves you know taking some of these
capabilities and going through the
content creating the tags and hosting
this on a server either locally or
selling the content which would be
refreshed quarterly would be a huge
service for small to medium customers
and even large customers that are not
academic one of the other areas would be
a real-time decision support and we've
seen some of that occurring with the
pediatric head trauma consortium there's
a group of about five pediatric academic
centers that are taking five or six
patient attributes and sending that
de-identified data to a central server
that's being hosted between Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia Denver
Children's and and a number of other
sites and based on the patient's
characteristics related to their head
trauma whether it's you know loss of
consciousness whether they've had a
seizure whether they have a headache or
other symptoms it will send back a
personalized workup for that patient
whether that patient needs a CT scan of
the head or not whether that patient
needs to be admitted and observed for 24
hours or any other additional work up
this is really the only one where we
actually see real-time personalized
decision support but I think there are
huge opportunities to peep for people to
develop those algorithms host those and
then generate the documents in protocols
that would go back to different sites
another interesting example is I ran
across an algorithm that they had
created and Radboud University in the
Netherlands and they actually have an
algorithm that will look at 40,000
different diagnoses
and I think it's looking at five to
seven patient attributes they can narrow
down forty thousand diagnosis down to
about three or four using an algorithm
but finding those areas where you can
take rules and host those externally and
feed those back to EMRs epic and non
epic is a huge opportunity for improving
care the other thing that's exciting is
is you can imagine that if a drugs
recalled and you're pushing out
protocols with actionable XML objects
within them you could withdraw a drug
from one of those protocols immediately
and substitute something else if there's
a better treatment you can immediately
act on that and if it's querying a
central server you could change and
influence care almost immediately if we
had this sort of capability set up one
of the other areas is interpreting and
integrating basic science and EHRs
there's a lot of screening
recommendations we can look at National
Institutes of Health and CDC
recommendations for genomic markers
we've had some sites such as University
of Virginia take all of those and
translate those into health maintenance
alerts where it will change screening
protocols based on different markers
certainly some of the other things that
would be neat to see in there since most
DMR's have the capability of using that
genomic data is how does that affect
narcotic dosing how does that affect
drug choices for specific patients and
really getting down to the level where
we're personalizing care based on data
within the health record one of the
areas that's been a challenge with this
is HIPAA and some of the area's we've
come up with to get around that is
patient sharing genomic data with other
family members directly so for example
in my chart the patient portal a patient
could decide that they want to share the
fact that they have a breast cancer
marker with maybe granddaughter's their
daughter maybe with cousins and they're
the ones making the choice to share
their own personal health data with
other people
which circumvents the whole HIPAA
problem of the health care provider
doing that it's certainly better ways
that we can come up with sharing data
directly as well as in a de-identified
way to personalized medicine one of the
other exciting areas is just the
incredible amount of hardware and
devices that can be used to change care
and this is something that we've seen
huge leaps in whether it's iPad
smartphones stuff that has computational
power that you can take in your pocket
that didn't exist until recently some of
the areas that we're looking at that
would be great for your simulation lab
is how to really change work flows from
the typical registration desk where
patients move around throughout an
organization for example coming up with
concierge types of care where someone
has an ipad they see a picture they take
the patient directly back to a room and
most of the care is delivered in a room
having on a touchscreen and on monitors
in the room the visit roadmap first you
know the nurse is going to come in and
do this then we're going to do a blood
draw kind of leading them through and
giving them an idea of how that care is
going to continue throughout what
they're going to do with the
organization bringing services to the
patient and staving instead of having
the patient move around the hospital or
the clinic some of the area's we've
looked at is actually using smart phones
and iPads to actually direct staff which
room to go to next and what blood draws
to do which room to go to next to do an
EKG in the clinic instead of sending the
patient to the EKG lab sending them
directly to the lab and really changing
the way that healthcare is delivered
within an organization and then even on
the inside corridors having directives
for the providers you know where the
patients at in the process so instead of
kind of the colored flags above the door
if he had two entrances into the room
putting some interactive stuff to kind
of direct the staff as to which room to
head to next some of those dashboard
views in the central work areas and
touch screens to direct doctors and
nurses which patient to do next even in
x-ray areas clinic areas and so forth
and then room layout I heard that
there's some architects and others in
your informatics program or people with
those types of backgrounds a lot of
attention is going into room design is
it better to have swinging tables to
move stuff closer to the patient our
mechanical arms better than using an
iPad which may have a keyboard and may
have some limitations for data entry and
then even some alternative room
configurations where you think out of
the box and maybe put desks in the
corner where maybe you can get three or
four chairs around in patients and
physicians and clinicians can huddle
around look at screens and discuss a
case but i was thinking with your
simulation lab these are great
opportunities to set up different room
layouts bring in patients and have them
sit and see what promotes the best
interaction what minimizes the back time
that the patient has with the doctor
where he's facing a keyboard and a
terminal and providing care and then
really some interactive screens what
sort of content is valuable as far as
sharing with the patient where you
almost make it like a whiteboard that is
displaying patient-level data along with
patient-level data that's interactive so
this is a touch screen where you could
actually grab the pulse and the nurse
could slide the pulse value down change
the blood pressure readings with the
arrows but at the same time you could
discuss with the patient whether they're
meeting blood pressure goals where their
BMI is and whether they need to lose
some weight but making the data entry
interactive at the same time with the
patient
and then leveraging some of these
screens for patient education patients
have long wait periods sometimes in
rooms physicians run behind I was guilty
of that many times but even putting up
some patient education and videos where
patients could make better use of their
time where they could learn something
about a surgery or learn something about
diabetes management and using some of
this downtime educationally with screens
it could be mounted within the room
exactly yeah plus the other benefit of
pushing out patient education in the
rooms is patients will find ridiculous
stuff on the internet that has no
medical basis but you can kind of draw
direct them towards you know medically
accurate information that that won't
give them some crazy ideas about care
the other thing we've looked at is even
educational games for kids where they
can play games learn about nutrition and
even do some some educational gaming
during wait times and then one of the
areas where we have a number of
customers doing quite a bit is
telemedicine and I think with
accountable care organizations in
medical home this is something that's
going to really become a rage because to
minimize patients loss of time at work
and loss of time at school much of the
care can be provided using telemedicine
and we're doing some of this we have
some sites such as UC Davis and many of
our Minnesota customers doing this blue
cross blue shield actually reimburses
about 35 to 38 dollars per telemedicine
visit they've actually shown that many
physicians actually increase their
volume and revenue by performing
telemedicine by getting that
reimbursement even though it's at a
lower rate because they can quickly log
on take care of the patient and move on
with their care or even do these at the
end of the day and where we're going
next with this in the next seven to
eight months is actually supporting this
on the smartphone as well so currently
this requires a webcam or a built-in
camera on your laptop but using that on
on phones is going to be neat step
forward but you think of a lot of
dietary education you could have eight
or nine different patients logged on and
you could be doing an interactive
diabetes teaching via telemedicine save
people drive time and lost time from
work remote consults you could do remote
consults with patients who may be 2-3
hours away follow-up visits great ways
to really leverage technology and
minimizing lost time for the patient and
provider so this is some of the stuff
that we currently support with the
smartphone feature coming out soon some
of the other areas that are interesting
as data aggregation and clinical in
clinical research on large cohorts we've
developed in epic a data warehousing
solution which we're looking at pooling
among multiple customers and we have a
number of customers such as one in the
st. louis area that has a lot of extra
server space and they're willing to host
and pool multiple instances of epic on a
single server where they could actually
churn through data that would be a
combination of several epic sites and
certainly where you don't have a large
enough number of patients to do that you
could do in a much more effective way if
you had say 10 or 15 million patients
instead of the two to three million
patients that you are working on so this
is something that that we're working on
and we have sites interested in finding
partner sites to do this with I know
Dartmouth is doing the same thing in the
Northeast but certainly if there are
those of you in the room interested in
that I could get you groups to get in
touch with start pooling some data some
of the other stuff that I think needs to
be addressed where we could use some
leadership is data data standardization
so the more data that's standardized of
course makes it easier to share
legal agreements really seem to be the
biggest impediment for sharing patient
data and doing research we've had a
number of states actually changed the
state laws to allow research as well as
data exchange in fact Wisconsin and
Minnesota both change their state level
laws to accommodate more data exchange
but this is something where informatics
can really play a leading role in
dispelling the myths and realities of
data exchange as well as research on
large cohorts where we can kind of
educate the public about D identifying
data and even ensuring patient privacy
if the data's not be identified and then
I think translate and disseminating the
findings I you know real time in near
real time through peer reviewed venues
some of some of the other areas that
I've found really interesting as I as I
travel is we have a lot of customers
using epic and other languages and when
I go especially to the Nordic countries
one of the expectations is is that
they'll exchange data between safe
Finland and Sweden and Sweden and
Denmark which it sounds easy because we
do that in the United States but to do
that across languages presents a whole
other linguistic challenge certainly
there's some data elements such as those
tied to sno-med which is
internationalized where you have an item
number for the diagnosis and for epic or
any EMR to display that in another
language is fairly simple we just
display the diagnosis and Swedish this
time or English but then there's other
other areas such as notes and other text
documents how do you get the key data
disseminated in another language we do a
lot of stuff with the Coast Guard and
and some with the Department of Defense
and State Department but how do we
exchange data for example with NATO
countries and other stuff and this is
going to become more and more of an
issue because no one really trust google
translate to run inside of an EMR and do
google translation of notes
obably a lot of patient risk but at the
same time are their natural language
processing solutions that could be
looked at to kind of reliably pull out
data and present that in different
languages one of the things that has
come out in our 2014 release is the
ability to date am on text note and
actually pull out the medication
symptoms at diagnosis as discrete data
and then click on those and add those to
the problem list and medication list it
would be really neat to have someone
look to see if that could be
accomplished across languages could we
data mined document in English pull out
a medication list and then convert the
medication list in the diagnosis list
into say Swedish or French or German
what would be the application right so
some of that I think relates to the fact
that people are just so mobile
especially in Europe a lot of these
countries have two to four million
people but people will travel all
throughout Europe you go to southern
Europe and there's a lot of areas we're
only forty or fifty percent of people
speak English whereas ninety percent of
people speak English in Northern Europe
if you got a patient who is critically
ill and you wanted records from Sweden
how would you do that same with NATO a
lot of times the US will pick up an
injured patient who may be with the
French or these multinational forces how
do you query their medical records that
may be in German or they may be and
finish or another language but I think
as a world becomes more and more mobile
this is going to become more and more of
a challenge
yeah the thing that's really been
striking to me is how different southern
Europe is from Northern Europe and
Eastern Europe ah I'll go to southern
Europe and you know forty percent of the
time the cab driver may know English but
I'll go to Northern Europe it's ninety
ninety-five percent but yeah same goes
with Eastern Europe there are definitely
pockets where there's less
english-speaking so one other
implication here of the language barrier
is as we're rolling things up for
research purposes and we're now starting
to aggregate this data at higher and
higher levels across the world and we're
starting to mine through those notes or
mind through those other text areas to
get implications for research you know
speaking English they may speak English
but speaking English and practicing
medicine in inning in English or even
asking a question in English apparently
are two very different things so so you
know yet another area that we could look
at I guess I could jump over here very
quickly and just show you some of the
features in our that are coming up when
you get to 2014 but this is actually
called chart search where I can actually
go into a patient's record here
this environment so slow in my laptop
so one of the features that we've added
is this chart search where I can
actually go in and put in you know
hypertension and actually have it read
through the note and find information on
hypertension so so in this case I can
see using natural language processing
that there's actually two items on the
problem was 24 notes 22 medications
related to hypertension labs and so
forth so this is a tool where I can
actually go through and just look at
labs related to hypertension just go
through the various notes related to
hypertension and actually go through
text documents and do this the other
iteration we have of this is something
called Note reader which will take a
text note and pull out discrete data
that you can then add back into the
database one of the the thoughts i've
had that no one's really looked at is
since we can do this with an NLP engine
many times it works in 20 or 30
languages would this be one of the
potential linguistic solutions for
presenting data in different languages
so this is actually using logic that's
being co-developed with m modal or with
nuance and then there's a third NLP
engine we're working with as well so
these are rules that are being
co-developed between the two what a lot
of this is using is groupers so will
basically have a hypertension grouper of
labs that everyone kind of agrees are
related somehow to hypertension and then
it's using a lot of grouper technology
for well groupers that get manually
created for labs medications diagnosis
and so forth to try to pull this stuff
up so there's actually a lot of
maintenance in the background that
that's being maintained with with
groupers essentially doing like a
bayesian on the backend you're doing a
bayesian of the yeah that I'm denim not
familiar with I haven't done a lot of
the development part of this and this
just came out this month so I'm just
starting to play with it and I'm sure
I'll be getting into some discussions
with developers some more but kind of
neat about how we're able to eat to
leverage NLP and you saw how fast it
queried about 200 visits on that patient
it took about 10 or 15 seconds to go
through with an NLP incha to do that
density is actually increasing
exponentially is my problem then of
course the other thing is is do you
actually potentiate misinformation right
you look for a term you just go through
a confirmation bias and realize that the
term you're looking for is there
therefore it must be true it must exist
so I guess the question is is what kind
of testing on the front end to see how
to actually you it's a very powerful
tool the question is how to best use it
yeah and that's been one of the
challenge is this is our first release
of it that came out this month and we
actually have a disclaimer that pops up
the first few times you use it saying
that don't you know rely on this is your
only tool and certainly provide feedback
and we're allowing people to provide
feedback because what we would love to
do is to continue to narrow down the
groupers narrow down the rules and try
to make it more and more intelligent
because I think you're exactly right you
could give back thousands of results if
you put in a very generic term if you
put in something very very specific you
might miss other stuff but how we're
going to be able to create rules and
algorithms is something where we need to
partner with informatics asst to try to
make this as safe and reliable as
possible some of the other areas that
we're moving into that's really changing
medicine and I think the eye tracking
research that dr. gold and others are
doing here I provides some exciting
opportunities when i first started at
epic you know pretty low resolution 13
inch monitors were common then you
started seeing 20 inch high-resolution
monitors now our latest releases of epic
support 24 inch 1920 x 1080 monitors
with very dense data on each screen and
really what is the best way to make
these usable is it to have some vertical
scrolling and be a little less data
dance is it better to have one pain with
some scrolling or three panes without
scrolling and what's the most efficient
way for people to aggregate data because
I don't
have a projector that will show this
I'll show you some screenshots but you
can see here we actually have three
panes in this particular example this is
orthopedics where they can create or a
test to a note do their billing and then
see all of the in basket messages and
results that have come back outside of
this visit and a test of those and move
to the next visit and you can certainly
create notes do those at test ations and
clear out everything with the seat into
single step so I can just go through
each pane and move on to the next
patient making it very quick because
everything is existing in three panes
now the next level we're going to is
actually allowing you to choose a body
region so every result order and and so
forth will be related to a body region
so if the orthopedist clicks on shoulder
it automatically filters down to all
films related to the shoulder all prior
visits related to the right shoulder
along with all surgeries related to the
right shoulder and then you only see
diagnosis related to the right shoulder
and then you can complete your visit but
by narrowing down data by one or two
body locations that you're addressing
maybe another advantageous way to do it
one thing that's very unclear is is this
the best user interface is the
actionable pain best on the right where
they create the note on the right side
is it better to have your actual pain be
the left or the middle one which pains
are best for data review I think with
eye tracking and other investigations we
can figure out how to to really leverage
a lot of the high resolution tools that
are out there because we can present it
in a lot of ways and you can configure
it almost any way
seems like at least in theory idea for
being able to narrow and deal with some
of the data overload but how far does
that go I mean your narrow you know
because there's a bit of a large
collection of tools and do we use the
the search tool to bring up things or do
we use this I mean can I narrow say if I
picked medication could I narrow by you
know the the indication for that
medication and all the side effects of
that medication all the dose changes and
all the related drugs and anything that
has an interaction I mean you know how
smart is it yeah and you know what
charts which we can do that and I think
there's going to end up being different
clinical uses so maybe in the clinic
body location makes the most sense so a
gastroenterologist wants to look at the
colon and he sees all the pathology
results for the colon all the barium
enemas all of the colonoscopies and then
he's really.just addressing the colon in
the hospital it may be problem-based
that makes more sense where you're
looking at sepsis or systemic issues I
don't I don't know what the answer is
going to be right and really what I'm
showing you are tools that could be used
but I think how they get used these are
things that informatics us are going to
have to figure out which is going to
maybe even you know involve some
randomized trials where you set up one
clinic one way another clinic the other
you look at outcomes maybe look at some
eye tracking what seems to be most
efficient with the least I movement to
get where you want to go do you see that
extending into the physicians training I
think so because all of these screens
now can be personalized where you can
actually delete and add things to the
header you can change your activities at
an individual level if you allow people
to have the security to do so you can
even rearrange the order of the
navigators and how you go through a
visit which I think improves efficiency
I think some of the concerns have been
is are there certain guardrails that
have to be in place like maybe
physicians can't delete code status
because that's just something that they
should see you know front and center but
I think physicians are going to start
personalizing more and more as we get
savier end users who start leveraging
some of the personalization yeah and I
think that's where you have to have some
overview screens and try to get people
to to look at the data i think there's
there's two extremes with the data
there's data overload because obsessive
compulsive people sink when they start
using an EMR because with a paper chart
you had you know your your problem list
on one page and maybe some sticky notes
the frontage art and you were
comfortable looking at two or three
different parts of the record some
people getting into an electronic health
record and they feel they have to look
at every tab they have to view every lab
every x-ray they're so afraid of missing
something in Betty being a medical
legally liable that they look at it too
much data but how do we in a smart way
present data so stuff doesn't get missed
but at the same time maintaining fishin
see which is which is I think a balance
between the two because I'll tell you
you can put a lot of stuff on a three
pain high resolution 24 inch monitor
which may be good and it may be bad as
far as it goes yes I know one challenge
that we've really had here with our
position some static go live not just
our position to all of our clinical
users has been them hunting through the
chart and looking and looking and
looking for data that's never there in
the first place and you know trying to
trying to teach around that and to say
well yeah there are 12 different places
you can look for orders but orders are
really all in one area so if you look in
one of those 12 places and it's not
there it's really not there and not spin
ending an hour trying to comb through
the chart looking for that cbc when it
actually never made it to the lab and
you never have a result anyway and it
had been a real challenge we worked
through kind of in that data overload
are we we haven't worked through yet
i'll put a towel yeah and a lot of that
we've really tried to push out to
customers and get sites to do this which
most don't have the bandwidth to do this
for every specialty but here's an
example of of a cardiology patient where
the cardiologist doesn't really care
about PSA values or the prostate
ultrasound but they really care about
these snapshots and on these screens
having the capability of seeing the
studies of notes so if I want to see the
cath I can see that if I want to open up
the the last cine run I can pull that up
directly if I want to look at the last
EKG I can pull up the EKG directly but
getting all the key data on a single
screen now that's a lot of effort on the
project team to do that for maybe a
hundred specialties where you have all
sorts of specialties and subspecialties
at an academic medical center now on the
other end what we've done which has been
somewhat controversial but has been very
effective is offering these free
physician builder classes at epic where
physicians from all over the country fly
in and learn to create and manage these
reports themselves that scares the
project teams tremendously to think that
doctors are going to go in and build on
the tech side and and do some of this
but with service with but with
sufficient security and guardrails you
can kind of give them the ability to do
some customization with hopefully not
getting into too much trouble if they're
just modifying their own Department but
this has been a move of trying to push
configuration to end users and away from
project teams
mission so how do you know if something
is not present in a record and sometimes
you have we have both it accuracy and a
precision issue where sometimes those
things are omitted because its data
dense it's on a screen where it is there
and you just can't see the forest
through the trees and then you go to
another view where you can see that
individual tree because it's the much
smaller for so you do end up going to a
lot of these different pages so either
smart filters or smart designs but I
think what it gets down to in the end is
a lot of times we come up and identify
these issues after the fact right a
perfect example was when we went live
with that back couple years a few years
ago we realized all of our hemodialysis
patients weren't getting any of their
antibiotics that were scheduled with
dialysis because it ended up on the PRN
list because it couldn't it's scheduled
after dialysis which is not at a
scheduled time and so patients weren't
getting any of it because the nurse
would go to the pier does it go oh he
goes to the PRS for things they think
they do it administer right so again
developing structured ways where you
have controlled environments to test
these so you can learn about the
unintended consequences i think is going
to be the key going forward instead of
learning about it after the fact when
you have a sentinel event i think that
would be the thing so i would say as a
company and for what we need to do as
informatics groups is our goal should
not be coming up with solutions based on
Sentinel events our goal should be
trying to anticipate that no events and
preventing them in the first place
through better testing up front right
and I totally agree and I think there
hasn't been a lot of that done and it's
a huge opportunity to do a lot of that
you know the NLP thing this is our first
iteration of putting NLP directly in an
EMR and we still don't know what the
bugs the good the bad are but I think
we're going to learn a lot as people
start to use it I'm sure they're going
to find a lot of data they didn't find
before but are they going to find all of
it and it will be or too much of it yeah
which is going to be something to look
at and then really the other thing
that's been a struggle and is figuring
out those use cases for tablets and
ipads we've seen a lot of sites put
tremendous amounts of money into buying
tablets iPads and other devices only to
find out that physicians don't use them
ultimately many times it comes down to
the fact that it's easier to enter date
on a keyboard a mouse is much easier
than than using a tablet or an iPad but
what is the the best GUI for doing that
you know isn't large buttons where
you're tapping buttons is it more of a
voice recognition with you know
generating discrete data elements out of
blob of text what's going to be the best
use case going forward we're developing
more and more of this and we're seeing
some areas where they don't do a lot of
data entry such as pre and post-op
anesthesia which ends up being pretty
amenable but then there's other areas
such as neurology where there's a lot of
complexity of documentation of cranial
nerves and other stuff where it's just
not practical to do that documentation
but figuring out where the use case is
for some of these portable devices where
it works where it doesn't are currently
on your smartphone you can prescribe
ambulatory medications and there's a
huge push from physicians to allow
prescribing of inpatient meds which well
maybe some impatient meds you could do
that but is it safe for even wise are
advisable to say order drips and tpn on
a phone maybe that's kind of a
ridiculous East case
exactly so but then you almost need a
different user interface because you've
got limited screen real estate versus a
large screen at a full workstation I
think we'd love to open it up and find
out you know groups that are able to do
it fairly effectively so we're always
looking at groups to partner or try this
stuff with because we don't always look
know the know the right answer some of
the other areas that we've developed is
personalized touch screens or wall
screens so when a respiratory therapist
walks up to a screen in the ICU it shows
just respiratory therapy stuff AVG's
event settings so forth when a physician
walks up he gets a different summary
view versus a nurse who might see the
Mar in a work list of things that she
needs to take care of we'd love to
co-develop that and and get input and I
think with your simulation lab where you
could set up different walls and rooms
with different hardware on it you could
really come up with some neat use cases
as to how to do this right exactly so I
wanted to leave plenty of time for
discussion and not use it all in just be
talking and throwing out some of my
needs and ideas of things I'd like to
see developed but you're always welcome
to email me pretty easy email address
Brett with 1t but at this point I'd love
to open it up for questions and allow
10-15 minutes or so questions rather
discussion
yes I have two questions one is sort of
regarding sort of the volume of
information when you stick information
in an EHR it doesn't have sort of a
physical instantiation so I thought have
you ever thought about developing sort
of a metaphor for the amount of
information that exists to give
clinicians a sense of how much
information they've dug through and how
much they still have to dig through and
a second question is have you thought
about implementing a system to enable
shared situational awareness because if
you have multiple clinicians looking at
the same medical record it would be
interesting to see like who's read want
pieces of that medical record I think
it's a that's a great idea that's
something we haven't thought of but it
would be neat if you know a two or three
different specialists are looking at a
patient you could see who's looked at
the the vent settings today or who's
looked at other data and say gosh no one
has taken a look at you know they're
there vasoactive drips and so much look
at their drips because no one's would be
great to kind of track that so no I
think that's a great idea you've talked
about a dashboard view and we we really
need some clinical sites to help us with
that but if you need to have a physician
dashboard that showed what they needed
to do which patients need to be seen
next and then on those patients what are
the legging problems that haven't been
addressed or no one's taking a look at
that day but it's a lot of logic behind
it
when you look at the ICU accordion you
have all these drips and things going on
so somebody who's just clicked on that
that would mean that they have
acknowledged everything yeah and that's
one of the areas we struggle with is
some sites use the audit trail to say
just because a physician went to the
screen they looked at the lab result but
if they clicked on that by accident and
then immediately left it how long do
they have to be on that screen for it to
be looked at which I think it would be
not completely perfect but you'd have to
get people to agree on what is you
having viewed the data Oh from the audit
trail is you don't from the work that
we're doing is that just because you're
on the screen doesn't you looked at
anything useful on the screen you know
with you know the example that we showed
yesterday where the one piece of data
that was the most important piece of day
on the screen was the one thing that was
not looked at even though everything
else was right and I think the other
issue is going to be and I think this is
maybe the real challenge is alert or
notification fatigue I mean I think the
perfect example is you know even though
a tooth was at ten years ago the IHI
said you know when the hundred thousand
lies campaign there would be no more
wrong side surgery right here no more
taking off the wrong leg or the wrong
arm or the wrong year whatever it may be
and ten years later that has not changed
in the United States even though
everyone does a timeout before a
procedure where they say okay we're
going to do a timeout we're going to go
through this and say this is mr. Jones
we're taking off the left leg right
everyone agree you know what we still
make the same mistakes as a country and
the reason being is that after a while
if you put everything into a checklist
or a to-do list or a task list the end
unto itself becomes completing that task
list regardless of whether the task is
actually completed right it says okay I
gotta go through all my list of NHS on
my dashboard I gotta go and acknowledge
the drip right good acknowledged do this
good acknowledge God do this good
acknowledged and then you actually do
less cognitive input as to it because
the the task is to complete the
checklist and so I think that's going to
be the real challenge with all this is
to try to balance to make sure you give
people enough task to do but don't
overload them where you get the same
task to do on everybody they get task
maybe sometimes it's about varying the
alert so maybe some days you make them
green some days you make them orange so
that they don't you know there's a lot
of ways to do it but the way we
currently design it probably is going to
fail if we increase the number because
it's already failing now the most
controversial thing that we've turned on
in the latest release of epic is a
feature where when you get a medication
alert you can click a button that says
never show me this again and you'll
never see that alert over again because
on yeah because the problem is in
oncology and a lot of these areas
everything's poisonous everything has an
interaction and they know it and they're
clinically aware so do they need to see
all these alerts with considering
bleomycin and all that stuff but at the
same time if you turn off that alert and
it's critical in another case it could
affect patient safety so we're very
interested to see how many customers
turn it on and what the feedback is from
that feature because doctors are
clamoring for it to get rid of some of
these worthless alerts but is it the
safest way to go but as a patient basis
is that provider based exactly that like
right so if it's bleomycin and you keep
pointing the chemotherapy for eight
rounds for the same patient once you
order a wood said you say okay for this
patient never alert me about this you
know I NH and rifampin the first example
as a TB doc right every time you
prescribe yeah the only time you ever
give I NH and rifampin together it's a
treat TB I know that they both are have
had a toxic and I know there's an
interactive there's all what reason to
ever give the two medications on the
planet so but for that individual
patient if you can keep on coming to you
each time you do that right epic now
tells me each time i prescribed
sildenafil that 40 milligrams three
times per day is three times those of
whatever and it tells it a hundred
percent of the time no matter if i
ignore it I don't ever want to listen to
that oh yeah and I think this is good
generate a lot of controversy here as
you go to the next version of epic are
you even going to enable that and
university to see what to see what I
mean there are a couple of points here
the
deserve a lot of further study want one
is this idea of opt-in versus opt out
alerts and maybe not one-size-fits-all I
mean I mean you've got opposite problems
with those kind of alerts whether it's
at the patient love or the provider
level or the hospital level or anything
and the second is is that is really kind
of the smartness of the alerts right if
we can state I never want to see the
alert in this case if I always want to
see it that case you know we should be
able to make the system do that right
it's not clear to me that it's always so
easy to get the system to do it both
from a technical point of view in a you
know sort of a manager appointed
organizational managerial point of view
but you know if the patients being
treated for tuberculosis don't show me
this alert right but so I think a
certain amount of the this both the
smartness of the logic and how easy it
is to implement that smart logic is
really an important thing a lot of these
are alert seem very reason people hate
them and the reason they get so many as
they're just very you know hitting it
you know everything with a very big
hammer and not really taking into
account the fine points of the patient's
situation or or the physician situation
this is where terms of the system in
terms of a diligent decision maker
shared decision-making where again for
example maybe we'll only alert you if
the cratan you know if it's a real issue
the Kratt knees over a certain level and
certain diagnosis are not on the problem
list right right so you have the problem
with there and no other laboratory
abnormalities that would pertain risk it
will cancel the alert for you you know
type of things so again it incorporates
other pieces of data and that may be a
better way to improve that data density
in some of these search tools where
automatic you put on medication epic on
the backend would say okay you're doing
inh and rifampin it automatically
searches on the backend tuberculosis
anywhere in either a note of progress
note a problem was yes look at the
l.f.t.s are they normal yes i will not
give an alert and i think this is a one
area where Europe is ahead of us
although they don't have as many
features and functionality because
there's minimal medicolegal
the number of alerts that fire are just
miniscule because no one's afraid of
gettin sued so like the drug database
vendors are afraid of lawsuits so they
have too many alerts the notes are just
incredibly short because reimbursement
is it based on the length of your note
so it'll say hypertension this is a
blood pressure this is what I did three
lines are done and part of this may just
be medical legal that's driving these
database vendors to put in too many
alerts yeah although I you know I know
it's some places you know they as an
institution usually led by sea mio they
go through and kind of prune out these
alerts and so you know there's there's
probably other ways to you know it seems
that it seems it's it's somewhat extreme
to go all the way to shutting them off
forever but on the other hand there's
clearly too too much now you know how do
you find that that right area of noise
it seems like you as a vendor are
occurring a really nice data set that
could be mined as well the configuration
decisions that all your customers are
making because like you're renting the
sea mio and a committee makes all these
decisions what level shall we turn on
and off of the alerts but if you can
start saying WOW and all these
conditions or you know the rule set so
that people have made through can their
configuration of your tool that would be
a great thing to maybe start thinking
about creating different levels of
alerting that might be sold as like a
package that people could subscribe to
right there actually is a tool where you
can actually track how many times an
alert fired when in the workflow and how
many times per there's actually an audit
tool for best practice alerts I can send
you some info on that if you send me an
email yeah yeah yeahs some customers use
that before they turn on alerts now this
wouldn't help with the medication alerts
to come from a third party but you can
actually turn on alert in the background
where the end user doesn't see it and
then get a report how many times I've
fired when they would have seen it and
so forth before you turn it on
clinically so you can tweak it in narrow
it down so it doesn't part
I mean I think this gets the same issue
though I mean if institutions are making
a decision on what alerts to turn on and
what alerts to turn off you would think
that they could make the issue of you
know what alerts to customize or what
alerts to have additional you know
conditions on in order to fire or be
active or not be active right I mean
sort of it's it would seem that that
would be a less severe decision than
just saying oh all these drugs they
fired do often we're going to learn them
all off right right this is one area
where I think again the the clinical
decision support being maintained like
an ohsu or by academic centers is huge
because if it was querying your server
for walla walla and a bunch of these
small towns out in eastern oregon they
could actually be getting these updates
and as you tweak alerts and all that you
could be getting de-identified data and
sending better and better alerts
regionally I talked about some of these
api's for exchanging data with these
things because it would just seem that
there's a lot of smart logic that could
be developed taken to these accounts as
long as you can get the data back and
forth you know an epic has had some API
is available but with the challenge from
the Department of Defense and
international customers to have more of
them they announced in September they're
releasing a huge number of AP is that
can be leveraged with epic so that'll be
an exciting area to see how informatica
start leveraging some of these with the
open epic yes oh and I was going to ask
you about that
yeah so is the open epic side up yet
matter okay yeah so that's some place
definitely that would be good to go as
far as that goes and I know that they're
going to be expanding that quite a bit
over the next month or two so I just
wanted to say on the content of the
alert you know one other complicating
factor of that is something you alluded
to earlier and that's all this outside
content that we're bringing it and all
this evidence based content so a good
example of that is we get our medication
database from first databank that comes
with a whole set of medication alert
medication alert recommendations and all
of that that we bring in so now if we're
looking at going and customizing that
every month or every quarter when i
implement an update first databank I now
have to maintain the customization of
the alert which is falling and that may
be good but it's an organizational
decision to do that and then resource
that appropriately so it can be done and
then it you know I'm always kind of
looking at the organizational the bigger
kind of regulatory perspective and the
medical legal perspective so now if I
made the decision to turn those
evidence-based alerts off at my
institution and I get sued over a result
I'm now have the potential of having a
legal exposure because there was an
evidence-based alert that I did not
provide to the provider not saying it's
a possibility or not saying it's a
probability but there's a possibility of
greater exposure and I think there needs
to be more feedback with those so some
like IMO which provides kind of
extensions to sno-med with synonyms for
icd-9 and all that they've been very
good because any customer can send
feedback that they need more synonyms or
to change them and sometimes they'll get
huge numbers of requests a month I don't
think there's really been that
interaction with first databank to have
groups of hospitals say you just need to
turn these off because none of us want
to manually turn these off quarterly
when we get up
it's that maybe more direction from end
users would be valuable that might be
another way to do it is to see if you
turn on don't show me this alert again
is sending them the data back from sites
that 99% of physicians always say I
never want to see this alert again you
should just turn it off or if it's a
hundred percent you know just don't
don't show it although maybe it should
be like opting out of email that they
eventually find some way to get it back
to you yeah yeah you know you opt out
and then like I don't know a month or a
year later you're back on their list so
some excuse to sort of put it back in
and then have you opt out again right
and well and I think the real thing is
is what is going to be your threshold
for an opt out because I think you
always have to worry about the inmates
running the asylum right so you get to
the point where people will say you know
was it eighty percent of docs will say
that they've never made a mistake but
they will say that eighty percent of
their colleagues have right it's so and
that 8020 rule works for just about
anything with physicians conflict of
interest mistakes plagiarism malpractice
you name it twenty percent will bid it
but eighty percent think their
colleagues do it and so when you see
when people want to opt out of something
you have to also that have the ability
to then go and say is this truly safe
and effective safety because just
because someone wants something somewhat
doesn't mean it's better I'd be the
perfect example the way that people want
the quote unquote progress don't to look
or a lot of our screens get designed in
a completely irrational when saying I
want these eight things on there as well
without realizing that that actually may
be causing more harm than good so just
careful when the inmates running the
asylum right